معنا منور الان مارسن زاباروسكي عضو مجلس
الاستشاري للعلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
البولندي ومدير برنامج الامن في مؤسسه
جلوب
مارسن ماذا في اخر المعلومات ما هي
المعلومات حول هويه هذه الصواريخ
كل ما استطيع قوله ان هناك
تقارير من ان صاروخين قد ضرب
المناطق الشرقيه لطولندا وانها قتلت تسببت
بمقتل شخصين
هويتي
مصدر الصاروخ واذا ما كان هذا صاروخ صاروخ
تم اطلاقه بطريقه متعمده من قبل روسيا
وانه كان هنالك يتعمد في الاراضي
البولنديه ام لا
ان لم يكن تعمدا ان كان عن طريق الخطا كما
ذكرت وسائل اعلام بولنديه ماذا يتغير
بالنسبه لكلندا
ام لا نعرف ان هنالك انفجار وان في خلال
ونتيجه لهذا الانفجار قتل شخصان
وهذه هي المعلومات المتوفره لنا حاليا
بدنا الواضح اننا سنرى اثار او ما تبقى
هذا الانفجار ونعرف نوعيه الصواريخ وعلى
هذا الاساس سنستطيع ان نحدد اذا ما كانت
هذه
الصواريخ صواريخ روسيه او يتم اطلاقها
بطريقه متعمده ام لا
اذا ما تم التاكد انها كانت صواريخ همم
شربما بولندا ستدعوه همم الحلفه من اجل
تفعيل البلده همم الرابع والبند الرابع
انه هنالك مشاورات بين الدول الحلف وان
على القوات ان يتم وضعها همم على اهبده
على اقصى درجات التاهب واذا لم يكن هناك
اثبات ان هذه الصواريخ روسيه وانها كانت
طائشه بالتالي فان الروس عليهم ان يقدم
واعتدارا اذا لم يتم تقديم هذا الاعتذار
انا افترض ان النيته بولندا
ستدعوا من اجل تفعيلي البندي الخامس بمعنى
فقره الدفاع المشترك
موسكو حتى الان عن على لسان او عبر وزاره
الدفاع نفذ ان تكون هذه الصواريخ روسيه
وقالت ان حتى الصور التي بثت عن اثار هذه
الصواريخ تبين ان هذه الصواريخ ليست روسيه
هل لديك تعليق على هذا الامر
روسيا ينكرون هذا الامر لكنهم في حقيقه
الامر لم يقدموا همم
لم يعلقوا على
تفجيرات مثلا كان هنالك مزاع ام روسيه
سابقه في اوكرانيا كانت خاطئه غير صحيحه
اذا قمنا بتصديق تصريحات الروسيه همم يكون
تحت الانطباع ان اوكرانيا تقوم بمهاجمه
نفسها وان كل المدن الاوكرانيه التي تم
مهاجمتها كان النتيجه
اعمال الجيش الاوكراني نعرف ان ما تقوله
روسيا كاذب علينا ان نفترض انه على رغبه
من انكار روسيا في هذه الحاله لهذه
الحادثه لا يمكننا ان نصدق ما تقوله روسيا
حتى لو انها قالت ذلك
شيلز بانديه
الصواريخ كانت روسيه سيكون هنالك توقع
اللي
اعتذار وايضا تعويض لضحايا هذه الصواريخ
وربما لهذه الهجمه الغير متعمده
رؤيتك وتحليلك ما المصلحه الروسيه
باستهداف بولندا في هذه المرحله من الحرب
ما الذي يمكن ان تتوقع روسيا تحقيقه من
وراء هذا الاستهداف
سيد الراشد
روسيا قامت بهذا الامر بشكل متعمد نحن لا
نعرف ذلك لحد الان نحن فقط ببساطه لا نعرف
هذا الامر ربما انه كان حادثا ربما كان
صاروخا طائشا لكننا بالتاكيد لا يمكننا ان
نستبعد نظريه ان هذا الامر كان استفزازا
روسيا وان روسيا تريد ان تجرب بولندا ودول
حلف النيته الاخرى الى الصراع او انها
تريد ان تختبر تاهب القوات النيتوا لي ردي
الفعل تجاهلت لها هذا الاستفزاز اذا ما
كان حقا وتم التاكد من ان روسيا همم لم
يكن هنالك ان روسيا كانت وراء ذلك ولم يكن
ذلك بالتاكيد فان روسيا ستخبر كما ستخبر
العالم ان النيته لا يمكن ان يحضر بالثقه
ولن يكون هنالك ضمانات ولا يمكن ان نظر
اليه بعين الجديه تتحدث عن امكانيه دعوه
دول الناتو الى تفعيل البند الرابع من
ميثاق الحلف الذي يتعلق به وضع الدول على
اقصى درجات التاهب كما ذكرت لنا ما الذي
يمكن ان يستتبع ذلك
تدعو الى استشارات طارئه بمعنى ان القوات
توضع على في اقصى حالات التاهب وهذا يعني
ايضا انه قد يتم همم نشر قوات اضافيه
والدول
الاضعف على حدود اوكرانيا وروسيا
بق بق
الرجل هنا تقويه امكانيات الدفاعيه وتقويه
ايضا
القوات وامكانيات الردع هذا
هو خطوه قبل تفعيل البندي الخامس تفعيل
البند الخامس يعني انه سيكون هنالك
دفاع مشترك ودعم مشترك ضد الهجمات الروسيه
اليوتيوب اليوتيوب
مكتب
القوات الروسيه وايضانا ننتظر الى
تصريح مكتبي رئيس الوزراء البولندي ووزير
الدفاع البولنديه وايضا بيان من النيته
ومن البنتاجون بعد كل هذه
البيانات سنعرف امم تفاصيل هذا الحادث اذا
ما كان حادثا عرضيا او متعمدا ونعرف ما
حدث فعلا حسب تاكيد هذه المصادر
الصاروخين قال انما جرى هو الصعيد كبير
ويجب التحرك كيف تعلق على هذا الموقع
ايباد فقط ان النيترو
للديه سياسه واضحه
في مسالتي الرد على اي اعتداء على اراضي
دول الناتو عندما كان الرئيس قبل ثلاثه
اشهر قال اننا لن نسمح
مسي اي انسان من اراضيته اذا ما تم
التاكيد على ان روسيا قامت بهذا الخرق
وهاجمت اراضي دول النيته وقامت بهذا الامر
بشكل متعمد بالتالي اعتقد انه سيكون ذلك
رد عسكري اذا ما قامت روسيا بهذا الامر
بشكل غير متعمد وكان صار كانت هذه
الصواريخ حادثه عرضا على روسيا ان تعتذر
على ما قامت به شكرا
عضو المجلس الاستشاري للعلاقات الخارجيه
بمجلس الشيوخ البولندي ومديره برنامج
الامن في مؤسسه جلوب السكه